beauregard au nord de rennes un quartier
du futur en pleine expansion et en
devenir le centre d'information sur
l'urbanisme se penche sur son présent et
son futur élément important très attendu
dans cet ensemble de plus de 2000
logements à terme le centre commercial
le centre commercial va voir le jour à
partir d'octobre 2003 donc ça veut dire
un désengagement du chantier en 2002 le
centre commercial qu'est ce que ce sera
donc c'est vrai que ce serait un lieu de
vie un lieu de rencontre des habitants
ce sera certainement à un supermarché
une supérette dans un premier temps
peut-être qui ira vers un supermarché et
lorsque y aura plus d'habitants dans le
quartier et puis une dizaine de
boutiques un centre commercial annoncé
dans deux ans et demi mais aujourd'hui
l'absence totale des équipements de
quartier se fait de plus en plus sentir
certains habitants arrivés ici en 98 ont
des attentes très précise ou crèche est
ce qu on est obligé de descendre à
villejean une école aussi et puis
quoi encore une mairie pourquoi pas
un de ses souhaits pour être bientôt
satisfaire l'école ouvrira ses portes
dans un peu plus d'un an pour la rentrée
de septembre 2002 en attendant le
quotidien de sannine au rythme des
chantiers qui façonnent le dernier des
grands quartiers rennais